.
PEOPLE WE HAVE SPOKEN TO SAY
THEY FINALLY FEEL THEY ARE ABLE
TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST THE WAR
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
THE CONSEQUENCES.
TO PROTEST PUTIN'S WAR, A RAP
ARTIST CANCELED CONCERTS.
HE KICK STARTED THE FIRST OF HIS
RUSSIANS AGAINST WAR CHARITY
GIGS IN ISTANBUL.
PROCEEDS FROM THIS CONCERT
STREAMED LIVE WILL BE GOING TO
UKRAINE.
AND DONATIONS CAME ROLLING IN
FAST.
TICKETS FOR THIS EVENT SOLD OUT
PRETTY MUCH IMMEDIATELY.
IT IS PACKED HERE.
BUT NOT EVERYONE IS HERE FOR THE
MUSIC.
.
>> I WANT TO MEET PEOPLE WITH
THE SAME VIEWS AS ME.
I WANT TO MEET WITH THEM AND TO
FEEL THAT I AM NOT ALONE WITH
THIS POSITION.
>> Reporter: 28-YEAR-OLD ANATOLI
IS NOT ALONE.
MANY LEFT RUSSIA IN RECENT DAYS,
ESCAPING A CRACKDOWN ON DISSENT
WHERE THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN
DETAINED AT PROTESTS, EVEN
CALLING PUTIN'S INVASION A WAR.
>> WHEN POSTING SOMETHING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, AT LEAST WE KNOW
NOBODY IS GOING TO COME FOR US.
AT HOME THEY HAVE A LAW IF YOU
POST SOMETHING, YOU CAN BE
ARRESTED.
AT LEAST WE CAN SPEAK OUT FROM
HERE.
>> MASHA AND DARIA HAVE HAVE NO
PLAN.
THIEF JUST BOUGHT PLANE TICKETS
AND LEFT THE COUNTRY.
>> IT WE ARE NOT FEELING SAFE
THERE.
WE ARE AFRAID OF THIS IRON
CURTAIN THING.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE HERE TO
HELP UKRAINE.
IT'S THE LEAST THEY CAN DO, THEY
SAY.
>> IT IS HARD WHEN YOU ARE ON
THE SIDE OF THE AGGRESSOR.
YOU FEEL RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU FEEL SHAME.
YOU ARE ALSO A VICTIM OF THE
SITUATION BECAUSE BACK HOME IT
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE -- IT'S VERY
HARD TO UNDERSTAND WHAT CAN YOU
DO.
>> Reporter: THE CROWD
SPONTANEOUSLY CHANTS WHAT THEY
COULDN'T BACK IN RUSSIA, NO TO
WAR.
TONIA JUST ARRIVED IN ISTANBUL.
SHE WAS FINED IN ST. PETERSBURG
FOR TAKING PART IN PROTEST.
SHE HAD TO LEAVE HER PARENTS
BEHIND.
OPPOSING THE WAR HAS EVEN TORN
APART HER OWN FAMILY.
>> THEY WATCH TV AND THEY SEASON
TO PROPAGANDA.
IT'S HARD BECAUSE NOW MANY, MANY
FAMILIES ARE DIVIDED BETWEEN THE
TWO SIDES, THOSE WHO ARE AGAINST
WAR AND THOSE WHO UNFORTUNATELY
SUPPORT.
BUT THEY EVEN DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY SUPPORT.
>> TONIA, DO YOU HAVE HOPE YOU
WILL HAVE A FUTURE IN YOUR
COUNTRY SOME DAY?
>> DURING THE PUTIN REGIME, NO.
NO, DEFINITELY NOT.
>> Reporter: THERE IS SO MUC